you have proven many times
that you are prepared in most complex
situations to act very effectively
and resolve the most difficult and
responsible tasks
and you always carry out your military
duty with honor for the benefit of our
country and our citizens in order to
ensure our national interests
heroic traditions
of spetsnaz
began in the many century of our
army's history and they were
strengthened during the
second world war and they were
strengthened in afghanistan and many
other
what points on the planet on the
northern caucasus in syria
you know how
dynamic the nature of the modern
conflict is
the commanders of the special forces
units need to constantly improve their
military skills
and
hone their skills of handling the latest
equipment and of course they have to
apply
the latest
developments the latest achievements in
the military skills
in order to handle any potential enemy
we know
that you are undergoing this
comprehensive and intensive training
a real
military school
please use the best examples of honor
in your military history
and bring up the new generations of
defenders
pass on your experience to the younger
servicemen i would like to
thank the commanders
and the servicemen and the veterans of
the
special forces
for an impeccable service for the
benefit of russia
and our people
i'm especially grateful to those who are
heroically carrying out their duty
in the course of the special operation
to assist
donbass and lugansk republics i wish you
luck
success and all the best to you and to
your close ones